tu ne l'es pas, je
t'ai dit
plus de vacances pendant que je suis en vacances, je vais
juste flotter, viens ici M. Parker, merci
Marcus et Emily Parker, vous n'avez pas
informé votre compagnie aérienne que vous êtes des
délinquants sexuels enregistrés
[Rires] qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce bordel  Ce n'est pas bien avec toi,
regarde-nous encore tous ensemble, nous
voulions juste vous offrir une vraie lune de miel, je viens de
trouver ça en train de ramper sous notre table,
il rampe,
c'est un prodige, c'est incroyable, cet endroit est
sympa,
ils seront partis depuis longtemps au moment où j'arriverai
à mon anniversaire.  nous devons être M.
Parker, excuses pour le changement d'
horaire M. Young vous a invité à
prendre un verre, vous tous, j'ai besoin que vous soyez
vraiment cool, pouvez-vous faire ça pour moi
[Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements]
regardez qui vous '  Je parle à quand n'avons-nous
jamais été cool,
juste sortis de San Clinton,
je t'ai offert le meilleur cadeau de mariage,
pourquoi cette noix de coco a-t-elle un goût de Cokey
parce que c'est ta mère, c'est vraiment plutôt
beau si tu y penses, non,
il y va du tout, il fait froid.  Marcus est
cool, nous flottons, ne touchez pas à
ma femme
depuis qu'il est arrivé, il a transformé ces
vacances reposantes en famille en
chaos total, qui a fait ça
[Applaudissements]
nous avons vécu l'enfer,
pourquoi ne pas y retourner, je le savais
poulet, il ne reste plus qu'une chose à faire
monsieur, merci,
je n'ai jamais vu combien d'eau monter à une
personne avant que
votre trou du cul vomisse un bourgeon
[Musique]
étrangère